MOST BEAUTIFUL WOMAN IN THE
WORLD?
MOROCCO IS GOING TO GET A LOT OF
TARIFFS.
NO ONE WILL SURVIVE THAT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
FRENCH-AMERICAN WINE WAR.
THERE'S BEEN TARIFFS THROWN
AROUND, THREATS.
THIS IS A TRADE WARM GOING TO BE
FOLLOWING CLOSELY.
IT DOESN'T REALLY AFFECT ME TOO
MUCH BECAUSE I DRINK TRUMP WINE
AND TARIFFS DON'T REALLY APPLY.
BUT I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
OWN VINEYARDS AND THEY CAN'T GET
ANY OF THEIR CABERNET'S SOLD IN
FRANCE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
COMPETE IN THE MARKETPLACE.
I LIKE HOW TRUMP IS STICKING UP
FOR THE BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS IN
SONOMA VALLEY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE THE HARDEST
WORKING PEOPLE YOU EVER SEE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED NOT
TO BE THE PRESIDENT ARE NICE BUT
TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF
NAPA VALLEY.
THESE NAPA VALLEY CABS CAN'T
COMPETE IN TARIFFS.
I THINK THIS IS AMERICA FIRST AT
ITS FINEST AND I SAY WE GO AFTER
THE CHEESE NEXT.
>> Greg: I THINK THERE IS
GOING TO BE A CASE OF SOMETHING
ARRIVING SOON FOR YOU.
>> Jesse: TRUMP WINE.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO DEFEND
MACRON.
I THINK HE WAS ACTUALLY KIND OF
SAYING WHAT TRUMP WANTED WITCHES
WE SHOULD HAVE A EUROPEAN ARMY.
WE SHOULD DEFEND OURSELVES,
RIGHT?
ISN'T HE KIND OF AGREEING WITH
TRUMP?
>> Juan: I THOUGHT TRUMP CAME
BACK AND SAID IF IT WASN'T FOR
US, YOU WOULDN'T EXIST.
I THINK HE WAS SAYING YOU DON'T
NEED AN ARMY.
YOU SHOULD PAY YOUR DUES TO
NATO.
>> Greg: MACRON WAS KIND OF
THING IF YOU WISH JUST BUILD UP
A BIG EUROPEAN ARMY.
I WOULD THINK TRUMP WOULD GO
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW.
I'M JUST TRYING TO GASP.
I DO THINK TRUMP WAS REALLY
UPSET THAT MACRON TOOK HIM ON ON
THE NATIONALISM WHEN HE WAS
SAYING THAT NATIONALISM IS BAD
AND CLEARLY TRUMP HAS HAD
RECENTLY THAT HE'S A NATIONALIST
AND I THINK MACRON WAS SAYING,
NATIONALISM MEANS WE DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE REST OF YOU.
WE JUST CARE ABOUT US.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY THE WORLD
GOES.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU THINK BACK ON
THE ARMISTICE AND WHAT IT MEANT
IN TERMS OF NATIONALISM AS
FOMENTING WORLD WAR I, BUT THIS
WOULD BE A RECIPE FOR A NEW
PHASE OF DISASTER, NOT LEARNING
FROM HISTORY.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE,
MAYBE NOT THE MOROCCAN KING, WHO
ARE MAKING FUN OF TRUMP FOR NOT
MARCHING DOWN THE CHAMPS-ELYSEE
CHAMPS-ELYSEES, NO AMERICAN
GOING TO THE CEMETERY, ARLINGTON
NATIONAL CEMETERY.
>> Jesse: WHO CARES WITH THE
MOROCCAN KING --
>> Juan: I CARE AS AN AMERICAN
THAT MY AMERICAN PRESIDENT AND
NO WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL
CELEBRATES VETERANS ON
VETERANS DAY.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IMAGINE IF OBAMA DO THAT.
IF OBAMA DID THAT, YOU WOULD BE
APOPLECTIC.
>> Jesse: PROBABLY TRUE.
BUT I WILL SAY AT LEAST THIS
PRESIDENT FINDS THE MILITARY.
>> Jedidiah: OBAMA DIDN'T KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
MEMORIAL DAY AND VETERANS DAY.
THIS WASN'T SOMEONE WHO WAS
BELOVED BY THE TROOPS.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THE
COMPARISON.
THIS IDEA THAT SOMEHOW
PATRIOTISM AND NATIONALISM ARE
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE, IT ACTUALLY
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
I KNOW EMMANUEL MACRON FELT LIKE
HE WAS BEING INCREDIBLY PROFOUND
WHEN HE SAID PATRIOTISM IS THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF NATIONALISM.
NATIONALISM IS A BETRAYAL OF
PATRIOTISM.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
GLOBALISM, WHICH YOU COULD ARGUE
IS THE OPPOSITE OF NATIONALISM
IS VERY EXCLUSIVE TO PATRIOTISM.
THOSE WHO ARE GLOBALISTS TEND TO
BE APOLOGIST FOR THEIR OWN
COUNTRIES, LIKE PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HE WAS THE ACADEMY OF GLOBALISM
AND HE WENT TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
HE WENT TO THE BRANDENBURG GATE
AND APOLOGIZE FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Juan: I THINK WE LIVE IN A
GLOBALIST, ECONOMIC WORLD.
>> Kennedy: I LOVE THE FREE
MARKET ECONOMY, DON'T GET ME
WRONG.
>> Juan: IF YOU LOVE
CAPITALISM AND GLOBAL MARKETS, I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN SAY
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON OVER THERE.
WE ARE JUST PROTECTING WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE, AND THEN YOU COME
INTO THE ENERGY THAT NATIONALISM
TRANSLATES, ESPECIALLY WHITE
NATIONALISM --
>> Jesse: OH!
>> Greg: OH!
NO NO, NO.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S CODE FOR
NAZISM.
>> Juan: IS NOT THE SHINING
CITY ON THE HILL THAT ATTRACTS
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD.
>> Greg: THERE IS A
NATIONALISM THAT SEEKS TO INVADE
OTHER COUNTRIES.
THAT'S NOT THE UNITED STATES.
HE'S PUTTING AMERICA FIRST,
MEANING LET'S GET OUR STUFF
TOGETHER.
JED, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS WHOLE THING WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT?
>> Jedidiah: TRUMP REMINDS ME
OF MY CAT.
WHAT USED TO HAPPEN IF SOMEBODY
WOULD PULL HIS TAIL AND HE WOULD
LOOK AROUND AND GET AGITATED AND
THEN PULL IT AGAIN, GET IT MORE
AGITATED.
THE THIRD TIME, HE BITES.
HE BITES BACK.
THAT'S WHAT TRUMP DOES.
THIS GUY, MACRON WAS DIGGING AT
HIM.
YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE
ANTINATIONALIST SPEECH, THAT WAS
A DIG.
THEN GROUPING THE UNITED STATES
WITH CHINA AND RUSSIA AS PEOPLE
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO GUARD
THEMSELVES AGAINST, THAT'S A DIG
AND THEN SOMEHOW WHEN TRUMP
RESPONDS AND SAYS SOMETHING EVEN
REMOTELY LITTLE BIT OUTLANDISH
OR LITTLE NASTY COME EVERYBODY
BLAMES TRUMP.
IF YOU POKE OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
HE'S GOING TO STAND UP FOR THE
COUNTRY AND BITE BACK.
PEOPLE SHOULD LEARN THAT ABOUT
TRUMP.
THE CLIP OF THE KING OF MOROCCO
WAS THE BEST THING I'VE EVER
SEEN IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
AS A FORMER TEACHER WHO HAD MANY
STUDENTS FALL ASLEEP IN THEIR
CLASS, THAT'S THE BEST.
>> Kennedy: YOU KNOW WHO ELSE
LOVED THAT JEB BUSH.
>> Jesse: LOW-ENERGY KING.
>> Kennedy: >> Jedidia
>> Kennedy: >> Jedidi:
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiW
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiR
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiE
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiY
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiU
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiW
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiI
>> Kennedy: >> JedidiG
TO SEE, IF HE OPENED HIS EYES
AND YOU JUST SEE TRUMP STARING
AT YOU.
>> Jesse: I THINK WE ARE
BURYING THE LEDE, GREG.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT FRANCE
STANDING UP AN ARMY IN THE
CONTINENT.
THE GLORY ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
NOT SINCE NAPOLEON.
IT'S ACTUALLY GERMANY.
THEY SAID THEY WANT THE KEYS TO
THE CAR OF THE EUROPEAN ARMY,
THEY DIDN'T GO SO WELL LAST
TIME.
IT'S LIKE GIVING THE KEYS TO THE
SON WHO HAS WRECKED HER CAR
TWICE AND SAY WHO YOU GO AGAIN.
SHE SOUNDS A LITTLE BELLICOSE,
ANGELA MERKEL.
I THINK WE COULD SEE ANOTHER
LAND GRAB IF THEY GET ANOTHER
ARMY THERE IN GERMANY.
>> Greg: A LOT OF WHAT MACRON
IS DOING, THEY COME IN WITH HIGH
APPROVAL RATINGS BUT THEY CAN'T
GET ANYTHING DONE BECAUSE OF THE
UNIONS IN FRANCE.
SO YOU CHOOSE THE UNITED STATES
TO SLAP AROUND.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW IT WAS
DELICIOUS, TRUMP, IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR POINT, SAYS MACRON IS
SIMPLY ENGAGED IN DISTRACTING
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF HIS LOW
APPROVAL.
I WAS LIKE OH, MY GOD.
NO SELF-AWARENESS.
CRUZ KNOWS THAT WHEN HE SEES IT.
>> Kennedy: AT LEAST HE'S
READING THE CORRECT PAGE IN THE
PLAYBOOK.
HE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT MACRON IS
DOING.
>> Juan: HOW COME TRUMP
SUPPORTERS NEVER GET THIS?
>> Greg: TRUMP IS NEVER TRYING
TO DISTRACT YOU.
HE'S JUST DOING WHAT HE DOES.